glenn greenwald is an independent
journalist very independent he writes on
subs deck he joins us tonight so glenn
what i mean i i don't think you're
shocked by this but you do have to ask
why are they telling us this now
the evidence was overwhelming from the
very beginning tucker that the
emails were authentic and yet they lied
and lied and lied as you just showed
trying to convince people to not even
pay attention to them on the grounds
that they were disinformation that the
emails were fake now the new book that
just came out is from this young
reporter at politico who spent months
digging into all of these emails and
obviously had he unearthed proof if
these emails were forgeries and put that
in his book he would be a star you would
know his name he'd be a household name
he'd be on every tv show but because his
reporting said the opposite he found
even more proof that all those emails
were authentic which meant that these
media outlets all of them pretty much
with a few exceptions deliberately lied
to the public in the weeks before the
election by telling them that this was
russian disinformation when they knew it
wasn't true they're ignoring his book
he's a he's not a right-wing journalist
he's from one of those mainstream
publications he has the proof in his
hands that they all lied and they don't
want anyone to know it
uh do you honestly think that they if
you're nbc news if you're cnn if you're
the new york times the washington post
can you just sort of move forward as if
you didn't participate
in a lying campaign to influence a
political election
you know as you know tucker i was at the
media outlet that i founded when this
all happened and they were the ones who
published as well the claim that this
was russian disinformation and then a
week later told me that i couldn't
report on this story because the
documents weren't verified in contrast
to the cia lie that they had published
so all throughout the media this is
their prevailing mindset they know that
they have an audience filled with
liberals who hate donald trump and the
trump movement and their only business
model is to aggrandize those people and
they know that even if they lie and get
caught lying their audience and readers
don't care in fact like them even more
because they believe they're on the
right side so you have a huge numbers of
journalists who believe that they have
the right to lie and even when they get
caught they don't care because they know
their audience won't hold it against
them
you came on i think immediately after
you left the intercept and i i thought
it was said then but looking back on it
the media outlet that you founded
tried to make you lie or prevented you
from telling the truth i mean that's
just really sums up the moment we're
living in i'm really sorry that you went
through that i just think it's awful in
every way
but you're thriving obviously glenn
greenwald thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else